Hi Stillwater!
Hi kids.
Addy,
why don't we celebrate your race?
I didn't win.
Doing your best is reason to celebrate.
Thank you Stillwater.
Looks like pet sitting is going well.
Not really.
I really wanted her to like me best.
Is that the most important part?
No, I have to make sure she's safe and happy.
Guess I'm a pretty good pet sitter after all.
And a pretty good brother as well.
It's starting!
The lunar eclipse.
Wow.
I made cupcakes!
Oh no!
Thinking of things a different way
is good.
This time we'll try something different.
Sprinkles!
Good idea Addy.
Go!
Only those who try...
Like this.
...can achieve the impossible.
Very impressive.
We love your stories.